c'était une grande première sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
le championnat national vtt fsgt était
organisée ce week-end sur la colline
tellancourt plus de 500 coureurs venus
de 29 départements ont participé à cette
compétition
c'est l'événement de l'année c'est le
clou de la saison et beaucoup de
coureurs c'est leur objectif trois
acteurs principaux et surtout c'est la
région parisienne c'est paris c'est
saint quentin en yvelines
c'est l'image du vélodrome l'image de la
colline c'est une date particulière
comparé à d'autres courses sur ce site
de 52 hectares les organisateurs avaient
concocté un tracé de 5 8 km avec des
bosses des descentes et quatre côtes à
15%
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment pour un pur
vététistes chaque fois on est les
parcours à pour les routiers mais
aujourd'hui il faut être fort il faut
être fort techniquement fort à la
fort en bosses et avoir du courage
tous les corps qui a aujourd'hui ils
viennent pas par hasard je touche une
préparation
spécifique pour le championnat c'est un
parcours super très technique super
roulant et avec une bonne boss faut des
bonnes gens mais un moral d'acier parce
que ça va faire main le avec les
compétiteurs on va s'envoyer la boue au
niveau des résultats le vélo club est en
cours saint quentin en yvelines a brillé
la section a remporté un titre chez les
minimes avec florian richard est un
titre chez les vétérans avec alexis
durand maximo royer du vcs cahier lui
terminé deuxième chez les cadets devant
plus de 1000 spectateurs
une performance qu'il faudra renouveler
en 2010 est le championnat national vtt
fsgt sera organisée cette fois ci à côté
de brest en bretagne